before you die take heart I will destroy
your order and everything it stands for
hey youtubers is charlie happy Halloween
since there was no Legend of Korra this
past Friday I thought it'd be fun to
talk about the new Jonathan Rhys Meyers
Dracula series as expected it's a little
bit silly so let's do a super quick
recap and kind of set up the world of
the story and then talk about favourite
moments and do my review the series is
set in late 1890s London just to give
you some context for the world at that
time that's about 20 years before season
1 of Downton Abbey and world war 1
Jonathan Rhys Meyers is Dracula as the
picture kind of gives away he's revived
from hundreds of years of imprisonment
by Van Helsing fight this secret
organization called the order of the
Dragon the story is based on Bram
Stoker's original text but it kind of
gets crossed a lot with the Count of
Monte Cristo and becomes this revenge
story for Dracula and Van Helsing so
they're working together in this version
of the tale on the show Dracula does not
go by the name Dracula he goes by this
fake public persona called Alexander
Grayson he's posing as this American
industrialist who's moved to London to
try and sell his wireless power
technology he also has a very notable
American accent which I will talk about
during my review if you've ever read
Dracula or seen any version of the story
or retelling of the story all the main
characters are their van Helsing
Renfield
Mina Jonathan Harker all the characters
relationships on this show evolved in
the same way they do during Bram Stoker
story with the exception of van Helsing
that's one of the most notable changes
because now he's working with Dracula I
like to think of that as Winchester
style like when the Winchesters work
with Crowley it's all about the devil
you know so let's talk favorite moments
first off Jonathan Rhys Meyers is a
great actor I loved him I loved him on
tutors with the exception of the last
season a little bit thick a little bit
ridiculous but I'm really looking
forward to his version of Dracula on
this show even before I saw the first
episode I knew it was going to be a lot
of fun even if it was going to be a
little bit silly right off the bat the
ballroom introduction scene with all the
dancers dancing together they had just
this awesome synchronicity that made it
seem really fantastical and really
dreamlike I really liked the
introduction to the order of the dragon
that Jonathan Rhys Meyers and Renfield
gave us after the party they're all
looking at those pictures it was just
really nice montage and kind of set up
who the villains are on the show I also
loved the first meeting of Dracula and
Mina I feel like that relationship
is so important to the story of Dracula
that at any time the tale gets retold
everyone always pays special attention
to their scenes together but what did I
think of the episode overall well I
really liked it
but it was a little bit silly for one
really notable reason the accent oh my
god the accent all I could think about
when he was talking with that accent as
the Alexander Grayson character and not
when he was talking his Dracula was the
actual accent it was very distracting
I'm hoping that they kind of tone it
down just a little bit if the series
gets picked up what happens is when they
greenlight a show they'll shoot like six
or eight episodes and then they might
get picked up so usually they get notes
and the fans will kind of give feedback
so if they want to make changes it
usually doesn't happen till after the
eighth episode or so so if you think
it's silly now it might get better but I
do understand that it's kind of part of
this fake persona that Dracula is set up
for himself as this American
industrialist but I don't know why he
couldn't just use his British accent
when he's Alexander Grayson - I mean
there were people born in America that
still have British accents I don't
understand why he has to speak like he's
from Virginia I think what the SH owners
are trying to do is kind of imply that
the order of the Dragon won't take him
seriously because he's so American let's
talk about Renfield though I love this
version of Renfield I'll call him mega
Renfield he's like Renfield on steroids
usually every other version of the
character is really small and weak and
looks like they're addicted to heroin so
this is actually gonna be a lot of fun
it looks like he's going to be a nice
foil for Dracula I haven't really seen
enough of Mina and Jonathan Harker
together to do a real assessment of
those characters in a lot of the other
versions of the story they're really
kind of throwaway characters Mina is
kind of like this person who's just
waiting to be rescued from boredom by
Dracula and Jonathan Harker is just not
a viable romantic rival for any other
version of Dracula but I think they're
really trying to develop those
characters on this show and set up Mina
is this really ambitious young woman and
Jonathan Harker is this really well
acquitted reporter so I'm interested to
see how those characters develop and
let's end by talking about one of the
most important characters van Helsing
it's all about the devil you know I love
that in this version of the story he's
working with Dracula they kind of set up
that they don't like each other it's
just the devil you know so basically the
order of the dragon did something
terrible to both of them in their
lifetimes
so van Helsing kind of felt like he
needed to revive Dracula to fight them
but let me know what you thought of the
episode and are you going to be watching
every week
I'll definitely be watching but since
it's on the same night as Legend of
Korra I won't be doing weekly videos for
it if you guys really want me to talk
about it I might use my tumblr for that
so be sure and follow me on tumblr I'll
be posting my Walking Dead episode 3
video tonight around 9:00 p.m. Pacific
time be sure to subscribe to get it I'll
also be posting a video for the Tenth
Doctor revisited tomorrow since there's
no Sleepy Hollow as always if you really
want to help me out please like and
share this video you can click here to
watch that new Walking Dead video and
you can click here to watch my very
special game of Thrones Halloween video
thank you so much for watching happy
Halloween high five see you guys tonight